well on the show of the years we've kept
you pretty consistently a formed of any
weird activity in the skies above us
most shows don't do that they're too
embarrassed but we're not why would we
be if alien life exists it's far more
likely we'll hear from it before we see
it now a telescope in Canada reports
picking up a strange powerful signal
from far far away what is it exactly
Brett Larson has been looking into it
for us this morning anchor for fox news
headlines 24/7 on Sirius XM and he joins
us tonight with more
hey Brett hey Tucker yeah this is
definitely one of those what kind of
stories this is something called a fast
radio bursts it was detected multiple
times and it has many scientists saying
we need more data so a couple things can
be a fast radio bursts it could be a
neutron star with a strong magnetic
field two neutron stars colliding a
black hole perhaps and yes could
actually be an alien the latest
discovery comes almost by chance from
something called chyme it's the Canadian
hydrogen intensity mapping experiment
and get this the system wasn't even
completely set up when they discovered
the bursts now the fast radio bursts
found are from a galaxy very very far
away one and a half billion light-years
to be exact and it is just the second
time that a repeat of a fast radio
bursts has been detected and the object
chime found produced actually six
different bursts
Ars Technica reports that of the dozens
of fast radio bursts identified only one
other has produced multiple bursts and
this is actually kind of significant
more and more scientists are looking
into the skies with more precise
instruments to find these signals and
they don't last for very long this isn't
something you're gonna hear this is like
a fraction of a second and it shows up
on a graph now some astronomers have
considered the idea that these bursts
could be from intelligent life elsewhere
and with more scientists searching for
them we will likely find out more about
them and find more of them i I think
it's alien I'm gonna I'm gonna go out on
a limb and say I think I think it's
alien and I think it's fascinating that
we
we appoint a radio receiver to the sky
and we pick up radio signals so granted
there are scientific explanations for it
but so to flip it around I just want to
be sure I understand this I mean there's
nothing about it that I really
understand but there's no hard consensus
that this is a naturally occurring
phenomenon so there are serious
scientists who believe this could be in
intentional the sending of these radio
so there's it could be it could be from
the collapse of a planet it could be
signals that come out of a black hole
and if it is signals that come out of a
black hole that's awesome too because we
can then learn more about them it could
be a neutron star it could be two of
them colliding and again that's also a
very cool thing that we we caught it we
can now hear the the signature that it
makes when it when these things happen
in the skies above us and the galaxies
literally beyond the Milky Way if it's
alien and it's it's you know get Jodie
Foster we got to build the spaceship and
sender yeah I don't know I don't know
Dee foster